I'm Paul Berg I'm a retired professor at
Stanford Medical Center and I'm going to
reminisce a little bit about how the
recombinant DNA idea emerged I had been
carrying out experiments with a
colleague at Stanford Charles Janowski
and as part of the experiment that we
were doing we were using phage mediated
transduction the delivery of genes from
one strain into another using a virus as
the carrier of that new genetic
information a very important technology
that had been widely used and very
important in the development of our
current notions of the molecular biology
of microbes but at the same time I had
decided to move from my work in bacteria
to try to learn something about
mammalian cells it was largely to try
and test whether the ideas that had
prevailed in about gene function in
microbes was also applicable to
mammalian cells and I took a year off
and went to work at the Salk Institute
with renato dulbecco and to work on the
tumor viruses I chose the tumor viruses
because they were known to have very
small genomes and they were known to
transform normal cells into cancer cells
and that seemed like a nice place to
start because again using viruses that
have limited genetic information being
able to follow the expression of their
genes seem tempting more tempting than
trying to study the whole emmaus whole
genome during the time I was down there
it was reported that when sv40 or Polly
OMA infects mammalian cells virus are
produced but amongst the progeny there
are variants which contain only cellular
DNA and not viral DNA and that was very
similar to the bacterial transduction
system p1 which infects e.coli and comes
out as p1 particles but containing
coleye segments of DNA and it seemed to
me interesting to think about the idea
of trying to develop a transduction
system for mammalian cells to facilitate
the genetic modifications of cells much
as we had done with microbes but very
quickly it became clear that a single
virus particle could not contain very
much DNA in fact the limit is about five
kilobases and the prospect of being able
to find a gene that was present in the
human genome three billion base pairs
and find it in a virus particle that
contained five seemed pretty small so
but I like the idea that we can actually
introduce new genes into mammalian cells
and we could do it without a virus
particle we could actually take the sv40
DNA which was known to integrate into
the cell's DNA that infects and link up
to it some foreign DNA anything we
wanted to put into the Bamiyan cell and
so the first idea was could we get two
different DNA's join them together
covalently and then use them as a way as
a tran - singh agent and we had in the
lab a plasmid lambda DV gal it was a
small DNA molecule about 10 KB which had
lambda genes and appropriate genes that
it could replicate an e coli and link to
it with the three bacterial genes that
encode the gal operon the three and
encode the three genes necessary for
metabolizing galactose and the idea was
to take the two DNA's and join them
together and we had to develop a way to
join DNA molecules together and we
employed what was already known as
cohesive ends in the bacteria phage
lambda the bacteria phage has these ends
which are cohesive that is the two ends
can be joined to each other to form a
circle or they can be joined to
different molecules that have the same
kind of ends and so the idea could we
synthesize synthetic ends onto the two
molecules we wanted to join and that was
already known how to do it
there was an incident with polymerize a
or T on to the ends of one molecule and
a or T on the other so you have two
molecules one which has a NS and T ends
and if you mix them they come together
and that was the scheme we set out to do
and that turned out to be pretty
straightforward I think it was actually
done within less than a year and so we
were able to make the first recombinant
DNA although wasn't called at the time
first recombinant DNA molecule was part
sv40 and parts lambda DV gal and the
idea was to be able to propagate these
molecules in e.coli and maybe make
mutations in the sv40 sequence also to
transect them into mammalian cells and
to test whether we could get expression
of the exogenous genes so that was the
first idea and the first fulfillment of
that idea and that of course led
ultimately to the evolution of the whole
recombinant DNA technology except that
it became much easier to join DNA
molecules together through cohesive ends
created by restriction enzymes
you